news daily from science mission we are
going to highlight some of the
scientific research that is making news
in the last 24 to 48 hours researchers
have found a new way to transmit
noroviruses that cause gastroenteritis
now these viruses can be airborne and
spread by air up to several meters from
an infected person next researchers
found out the mechanism to asthma
induced by obesity in obese mouse models
higher insulin causes certain region of
the brain to send signal that causes a
style colon release in the airways
resulting in airway constriction aspirin
is known to reduce risk of colorectal
cancer but the mechanism is not known
researchers showed that core expression
of cox-2 with egfr protein implicated in
cancer cox-2 activates each independent
activator protein AP 1 which increases
the transcription of EGFR as pre
normalizes the EGFR expression by
blocking the cox-2 and its effectors in
the general science scientists provide
more clothes to aging they generated a
stem cell model without the aging
protein Werner that resembled the stem
cells from older people with the
disruption in heterochromatin integrity
were not protein interacts with the
heterochromatin proteins to maintain
chromosomal integrity for more details
visitors at www science mission calm or
science mission facebook page thank you